phenomenally impressive it is that he's
about to average a triple-double for the
fourth year of his career it's not just
stat stuff
he's driven winning at a high level too
and luther knocks down a three mark
couldn't agree more and you said pace 71
right now lin got to the rim but didn't
finish
watch will he run luca in transition
looks off the defense and he found that
running
willy caulistein for the hoop he looked
up here at you
what's up my man means this guy can see
you did look right towards you there you
go
dunks at home man that's good stuff
dallas leading by the 11th excellent
start to the game they want to close out
the first quarter well which they do a
luca dunk
another open lane for luca to drive
discombobular loves those 45 degree
angle bank shots but he missed that one
luca around a powell screen in the paint
spins fades and scores
say what if the mavs can force ish smith
into those types of shots that's good
defense
it's not his forte luca
that is his forte everything is his
forte tell you what that was not an easy
shot
love to score and manage this for a two
for one they want to go score stop score
to end the game
we're not gonna allow luca to do it but
he's gonna do it anyway elbow jumper
hits the pull-up
they did allow him a little space and he
hit the pull-up
there's luca the last possession pulled
the trigger
you're gonna have to
gonna have to go now to the corner it's
gone it's a go ahead three
finnish smith with nine seconds to go